[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my video all about why the night king
has seven pointed star eyes there was a
preview right before they released the
Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer they
showed us a really high-resolution
picture of his face everybody noticed
this special detail it started freaking
out so we'll break it down so if you're
new to my channel or you're just coming
back after the long winter hiatus
between seasons I'll be doing Game of
Thrones Season 8 videos all season long
and videos about the Game of Thrones
prequel TV show that's airing next year
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I also do book giveaways and
merch giveaways on a weekly basis not
only are the night Kings eyes seven
pointed stars but there's also flecks of
black around his irises that make it
look like he has many eyes within his
two eyes which is another Easter Egg for
a very specific book quote tying him to
a lot of other ideas within Game of
Thrones
quick reminder though that this version
of the night King on the TV show is not
a book character because as a book 5
Dance with Dragons right now George R
Martin has made no mention of a current
version of the night king leading the
white walkers in present day the only
night king that we know about is the
mythical night's king who was once a
stark of Winterfell and the 13th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch but Martin
claims that he died thousands of years
ago killed by an alliance of the
wildlings of the time in the start king
of the north at that time because it
happened long long time before the Andal
invasion long before Aegon's conquest
so Westeros was still divided up as
seven different kingdoms with seven
different petty kings but the Nike on
the TV show having seven pointed star
eyes is such a specific detail I don't
think that it's something that Dan and
Dave and the show's producers came up
with on their own so if you guys don't
remember way back after Game of Thrones
season 3 in the red wedding the TV
show's producers and writers met with
George R Martin it would have now known
as the famous Santa FA meeting where he
revealed the future of A Song of Ice and
Fire story to them because this was a
couple years ago he had even less of
winds of winter completed and they were
getting ready to start writing season 4
of the TV show so they needed to start
focusing on how they would eventually
end the show and even though George R
Martin had an ending in mind his method
for writing this
more like gardening a story which means
that he comes up with lots of new ideas
as he goes along for characters and
storylines is one of the reasons why the
books have been so amazing and why the
story becomes so sprawling it's also
become one of the biggest reasons why
it's harder for him to end the story and
finish the books at this point
despite that problem even as far back as
a couple years ago he still had a very
broad idea of how he would end the story
so that's what the TV show's producers
got so even though there's gonna be a
lot of details that'll be very different
in the ending of the books the TV show's
ending and all this mythology that
they're trying to tie together before
the end of the story will still bear a
lot of similarities to the books but
that's the thing the TV show does not
make up a lot of the mythology as they
go along it's all based on what they
learned from george RR martin during
that special meeting after that big
meeting they went on to write season 4
what happened that was really special
during season 4 we saw the night king in
the lands of voice winter for the first
time we learned how he created new bike
walkers using Craster's Suns or
potentially other sons of northerners
that sacrifice them to him there was a
lot of other things that George R Martin
revealed to them at that meeting he told
them the truth about the origin of Hodor
name so that they could do that season 6
episode 5 moment hold the door there's a
lot of big mythology and play during
season 8 that's also based on some of
the stuff that he told them way back
then this behind the scenes of the night
king in his face in his eyes is during
season five hardhome episode the behind
the scenes from that video is actually
really good I'll play it clip from it in
a second because there's a very specific
quote about the night king in Jon Snow's
moment then I think that they'll be
paying off during season eight
my King sees this and he sees John kill
one of his lieutenants and it's kind of
uh well this this kids interestingly
this kids actually possibly a threat for
me so he's very much looking at John
then when he does what he does at the
end of the episode
I think this script is very explicit
about it it says that the night King and
John share unpleasant exchange that is
not comfortable for John and and we
called it for ages you know and it's a
non verbal [ __ ] you I think it's a
terror John has never known before I
mean they're seeing the White Walkers
and then they're seeing the white Walker
King with an army of a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand three hundred
thousand Undead the final image of the
Nike in the Nike raising his hands was
all David and Dan they said they wanted
it to be like an orchestra look at the
night King's eyes here you can actually
see the same star eyes that you see in
this season eight preview image and even
though they recast the actor who plays
the night King it's obviously the same
basic idea they're not gonna completely
change his face it's just the structure
of his face looks a little bit different
because the actor who's playing him
looks a little bit different the sheer
amount of Mythology that they tie
together by making his eyes seven
pointed stars is such a specific thing
that I think it's all based on stuff
that George our Martin told them during
that meeting it ties together Easter
eggs about the three-eyed Raven the
children of the force the old gods the
faces on all the weirwoods and all the
religions that we know about within the
world of Game of Thrones including the
big Macomber Easter egg if you're not
familiar with Macomber is actually one
of old Nan's tales and it's a story that
Robb Stark is telling to bran Stark he
says one time she told me that the sky
is blue because we live inside the eye
of a blue-eyed giant named Macomber and
then bran stark says maybe we do so was
just a folktale within Westeros that the
world that they live in planet os-- is
the eye of a blue-eyed giant the iris of
that blue-eyed giant is the Isle of
faces which we know is a very elemental
a powerful place for the children of the
forest is where they use the hammer of
the waters to smash the arm of Dorne so
McCumber is a folktale that's evolved
from
real-life events in history there's a
very special scene during season five
when Aria first enters the house of
black and white in jaqen H'ghar is
giving her the grand introduction to
their ways she looks up at all the idols
representing the many different
religions of the world and starts to
learn about the many-faced God in the
context of the faceless men's orders the
many-faced God represents death it must
become no one
which one's the many-faced God I see the
stranger
I see the drowned God I see the way
woodface there is only one God I go
knows his name and all men know his gift
but even as far back as when the first
book came out in the 90s readers started
to theorize that when people talked
about the faith of the seven different
religion of the Andals the seven were
just many different aspects of the same
God the different aspects of the faith
are the father the mother the maiden the
Crone the warrior the Smith in the
stranger the stranger represents death
in the unknown just like the many-faced
God represents death so already on that
smaller level book readers are thinking
wait a minute it sounds like they're
worshipping the same idea and just
calling it different names think about
the timeline this way though the night
King was created during the children's
war with the first men thousands of
years before the Andals invaded the
Andals are the ones that created the
faith of the seven they brought that
religion to Westeros when they invaded
they themselves fleeing the East to
escape the expansion of the Valyrian
freehold so the night King predates the
religion of the faith of the seven he
also predates the concept of the
many-faced God the idea of the
many-faced God came about when slaves
working in the Valerians mines who all
came from disparate cultures in the East
that the variants had conquered slowly
started collectively worshiping the same
idea one of the cornerstones of their
order is that they all work as assassins
when someone names a name is part of the
idea that the slaves working the
balerion mines wanted to get revenge for
their subjugation so even though there
are a lot of geological reasons for the
doom of Valyria and the fourteen flames
all erupting at the same time all those
different volcanoes there's a lot of
people that think that it's a very
similar situation to when the children
of the forest used the hammer of waters
to smash the arm of Dorne they called
upon this elemental magic of the planet
in the old gods to help them out so it's
possible that the
Laoghaire enslaves worshipping the
many-faced God were also really
worshipping the same elemental force of
the planet in remembering that the night
Kings creation predates all of these
things happening it makes sense that he
and the White Walkers inspired a lot of
religions and ideas and customs that
came later so if the children of the
forest are calling upon this same
elemental magic to create the night King
it would make sense that he bears the
mark of that elemental force that all
these people are worshiping and just
using different names to call different
aspects of the seven the many-faced God
the faces on the weirwoods representing
the old gods the night King bran stark
the three-eyed Raven the children of the
forest all drawing their power including
Melisandre from the same place the same
elemental force thinking about the myth
of McCumber as a representation of that
elemental force the night king is also a
visual easter egg for that - the
blue-eyed giant he just the terrible
side of that elemental force there's
this long-standing theory about him
needing to destroy the Isle of faces in
order to bring about a permanent long
night that might be a detail the TV show
does not include we don't really know
about that yet the books go a lot deeper
on these theories and legends but that
would tie together to the Macumber
theory if the Isle of faces is the iris
in the eye of McCumber the other really
cool Easter Egg for the three-eyed Raven
is for the song a thousand eyes and one
which is actually a song about Brynden
rivers before he became the three-eyed
Raven when he was known as the blood
Raven and the song goes how many eyes
does Lord Bloodraven have a thousand
eyes in one so it's a metaphor for
Macomber but you also look at the night
Kings eyes and all those little flecks
of black in them that make it look like
he has many eyes in his two eyes the
Thousand Eyes Easter Egg was mentioned
during storm of swords so which is
another way early in the story of A Song
of Ice and Fire for Georgia our Martin
to seed Easter eggs and clues about the
White Walkers before you learn a lot
about them to say that all these things
the blood rape and the three-eyed Raven
the White Walkers the religions of Game
of Thrones are all things that are part
of the same idea everything is connected
post all your night King theories in the
comments below and there'll be more Game
of Thrones happening this week no
worries but congratulations to the
winner from my last big video Rob flower
please email me on the about page my
channel so it can get your details click
here to rewatch the Game of Thrones
Season 8 trailer a billion more times in
all
Easter eggs and click here for my
breakdown of that new night King and
White Walkers preview thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight